-Please welcome the stars
of the 2019 NBA draft.
On my team,
from Vanderbilt University
Darius Garland, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
From Duke, RJ Barrett!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
And our opponents,
from North Carolina, Coby White,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
from University of Texas,
Jaxson Hayes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
And from Virginia,
De'Andre Hunter!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
All right.
Here's how this works.
We're going to take turns
trying to shoot random objects
into that hoop right there
The most points win.
We can come over this side
The objects we're throwing
tonight is
the Fudgie the Whale cake
that says,
"Congrats, you're in the NBA."
We have a basketball shoe
filled with nacho cheese.
[ Laughter ]
We have a mannequin head
with a Knicks hat on there
A Knicks fan. Knicks is
a great team to play for.
I got to say.
[ Applause ]
And the money ball,
worth two points,
a giant water balloon
full of Gatorade.
Now, everyone come on over
on this side here.
We'll take turns throwing here
And, all right, Coby,
why don't you go first?
And then --
-You want to go first?
-You sure you want me to
show you how it's done?
-Yeah, you go first.
-Alright,
I'll show you how it's done.
I'll just say,
with the water balloon,
throw it with the bowl,
just cause it's a very sensitive
water balloon.
[ Laughter ]
Trust me. All right, here we go.
You want me to go?
I'll show you how to do it
You can throw underhand
if you want.
-Okay.
-Should I throw underhand?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I could do this one overhan
I think.
[ Globetrotters-esque musi
plays ]
[ Audience murmuring ]
[ Audience ohhs ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-This close! This close!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This close.
All right. You're up.
-[ Whistling musically ]
-I have to go underhand?
Underhand?
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-Yeah. How do you do this?
How do you throw
an ice cream cake?
♪♪♪♪
[ Audience ohhs ]
-That counts as a bucket.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-No, absolutely not.
-That's a bucket!
-That doesn't count!
-No, rejected.
Rejected. Rejected.
No, did not quite make it.
Alright.
Who wants to go next?
♪♪♪♪
Show him how it's done.
Alright.
-I got it.
-What is that?
[ Audience ohhs ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Can we play it off the boards
Alright, you want to try it?
-You got it, bro.
-He got both.
-All right, he tried to play i
off the board there.
♪♪♪♪
Don't overthink it.
Whatever you do.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
[ Audience ohhs ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-I thought you'd throw it
too hard.
-Bro, you got it.
-Right, Knicks fan.
-You got it.
-I got it.
I got it, I got it.
[ Laughter ]
I might put the hat on.
♪♪♪♪
-Ay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-It didn't even look like
he tried on that one!
You can throw it --
you can shoot it like --
Oh! Oh! Hey, whoa!
Yeah, I like that.
That was a exciting right there.
[ Laughter ]
I like that.
You can throw overhand
if you want.
Oh, he didn't even think
about it.
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh my God! Oh my God!
That's how you do it!
That's how you do it.
Now we are in the lead.
I'm telling you,
it's lucky in New York.
It's tied for the money ball
Okay?
So each team can nominate
who they want to shoot
the money ball.
This is worth 10 million points.
Okay, perfect.
[ Laughter ]
Whoever wins this -- all right
I think it's got to be you
-We've got to get you
another chance, bro.
-I think --
-He sacked it, too.
-You got to redeem yourself.
-No, I didn't --
-You got at least hit something.
-Yeah, at least mine went
close to the rim,
for God's sake.
-Come on, bro.
-It's all you.
-You got it.
-Do whatever you want.
-I got it.
-I'm going to try under.
-No, let them go first.
Let them go first.
We just went!
-You picked it up.
[ Laughter ]
-We just went.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
I scored. We just went.
-You made one.
-We just went.
-You can try. You can try.
You can try.
-Rock, paper, scissors.
-Rock paper scissors.
-It's between them two.
[ Laughter ]
[ Drumroll ]
-Hey!
-Yeah, let's get it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, champ!
-Alright, come on, champ!
-Come on, champ.
-Wait, but if you make --
Oh, that's right, so if you make
this, then you're in the lead.
Then we have to make ours.
-You're not going to
make it anyways.
-Take it out the bowl.
-I would leave it in the bowl.
Leave it in the bowl.
-Take it out the bowl.
-Leave in the bowl?
-I would.
-It's going to break on you bro.
It's going to break on you
-Oh, no,
I don't want it to break.
-Take it out the bowl.
-They're tricking you!
They're tricking you!
They're tricking you.
-He's supposed to be
on our team.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-We won! We won! You got to --
-No.
-Aw, man!
-Whoa! No!
-We're the champs!
Our thanks to all these
future NBA stars!